now fans were out in full force tonight
packed into a legion stadium for the
regular season home opener and for many
this was a night unlike any other orc oh
manna joins us live with what those
raiders fans had to say hi there orco
well brian there's nothing quite like
watching raider nation celebrate a
victory we've been seeing groups of fans
leave allegiant stadium and then come
out here to the sidewalk screaming and
chanting the raiders delivering on their
promise to just win baby
fans fired up after the las vegas
raiders thrilling home opener at
allegiant stadium
raider nation coming out in full force
monday night and celebrating a huge
overtime victory against the baltimore
ravens i was actually clapping
this fan also watched the preseason game
against seattle last month in person but
for him and so many others this regular
season win is so much sweeter the
seahawks game was okay
but this was
yeah
it was what made it different
the energy level i mean everybody was
pumped the electric excitement passed
down through the generations and a way
to remember those no longer with us my
dad was a oakland raiders fan forever so
yeah i think about my dad who's gone now
but it was great he would have loved it
seeing the stands inside allegiant
stadium packed with the silver and black
is something everyone has been waiting
for it was nice to see everyone just
kind of like come together and just
cheers and just yeah it was very lively
animated yeah
it was worth it
raiders fans hope this is just the
beginning of a string of wins this
season
now fans say they cannot wait for the
raiders next home game which will be on
sunday september 26th reporting live at
allegiant stadium tonight orca mana 8
news now